- [Voiceover] In 1992, Nickelodeon
debuted the TV show Guts.
It was just like American Gladiator,
only the contestants were all kids.
- [Voiceover] The rocks have tumbled,
the smoke is smokin'.
- [Voiceover] And while the
show was epic in every way,
the theme song is one of
those pieces where you start
singing it and somebody
next to you joins in.
So we found the guy who wrote it.
- My name's Rick Witkowski
and I am the composer
of the Nickelodeon theme song, Guts.
♫ Do you have it,
♫ Do do do you have it
♫ Guts
♫ Do do
♫ Do do you have it
♫ Guts.
♫ It takes deep dedication♫
When I got the call to do this piece,
hip hop was just coming of age.
Immediately it came to mind
that do do do do you have it, Guts.
They liked it and they said you think
you can put a little rap to it?
I said sure, I'm a Polish
guy from West Virginia.
I can rap, yeah.
♫ It takes a certain kind of something
♫ To keep the heart pumping
♫ Something everybody needs to achieve
♫ To succeed, you'll need a lot.♫
A lot of words, a lot of words.
♫ Do you have it, Guts.♫
They were big on the sound
effect stuff in that tune.
You can hear me in there, eww, ahh, ahh.
Aggro crag.
I sampled myself.
- [Voiceover] So Rick,
he didn't just write
the theme song for Guts,
he was kind of the 90s
jingle guy for Nickelodeon.
- Guts was my first, you know,
first show for Nickelodeon.
I did some music for The Big Help.
(guitar music)
Did all the music for
Kids’ Choice Awards.
♫ Kids’ Choice ♫
Figure It Out.
The remake of Family Double Dare.
- [Voiceover] Double Dare 2000.
- I did stuff for Nick at Nite also.
♫ Nick at Nite
♫ The place for TV hits♫
Oh but here's a show
that I forgot to mention.
I did the music for a show
called Action League Now.
- [Voiceover] Action League Now,
starring The Flesh.
- On my bucket list I, you know,
would love to be involved in
having a hit record, you know?
I'm still working on that, but
I guess you know to a degree,
like, the Guts theme, it’s my hit.
So I'm pretty happy about that.
♫ Do, do, do you have it?
♫ Guts♫